[Music]
director sam raimi made doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness into a
trippy visual feast but if you're going
back for seconds which scenes deserve a
closer look a viewing guide for round
two straight ahead
multiverse of madness opens on a
frenetic chase scene where america
chavez and a variant of doctor strange
are shown running from a monster through
a fractured dimension it's quickly
revealed that they're in search of the
mystical book of ashanti and that the
creature at their heels is after
america's dimension-hopping powers your
first time through though this info
comes pretty fast and furious and it
isn't revealed until later that scarlet
witch is actually the one behind the
monster's attack going through the
opening sequence a second time a number
of things become clearer you can really
take in the design of the monster
chasing them which has a cool ethereal
look the scene also drives home just how
driven scarlet witch is to claim
america's powers
the battle in new york city quickly sets
the tone for the kind of action viewers
can expect throughout and there are a
lot of little touches that make it a fun
re-watch the tag team fighting style of
doctor strange and wong is entertaining
and they each make creative use of their
spell arsenals during the fight
there are also some distinct bits of sam
raimi flare such as the brutal kill shot
where strange pulls the monster's giant
eye straight out of its body a second
watch lets you soak in how the design of
gargantos never called that in the
actual film by the way just in the
merchandise actually mirrors a different
marvel comics creature the eldritch
deity schumacher wrath due to a rights
issue the studio was unable to use that
name so they combined the schumacher
wrath character with that of the sea
monster gargantos from the neymar comics
at first doctor strange has no idea that
wanda is the one behind the attacks on
america in fact he decides her knowledge
of magic and witchcraft is exactly what
they need to fight back we need your
help strange journeys to wanda's remote
home to try to recruit her for the
mission finding her in an idyllic
orchard with no signs of her old life
she suggests that america comes and
stays with her but she makes one big
slip up dropping america's name before
she actually hears it from steven doctor
strange quickly realizes the truth and
it's revealed that the thriving
landscape is actually an illusion
covering a desolate wasteland going back
to the scene a second time you can see
just how carefully wanda plays her game
of lies she presents every possible
objection and repeatedly claims that
she's out of the superhero scene blowing
strange into a perceived position of
authority and power watching the scene
after you've already finished the movie
is also interesting because it
complicates the mistake wanda makes
she's so careful and so cunning for so
much of the movie that it feels bizarre
for her to make such a simple slip up
later on it's revealed that wanda's core
personality has been locked away within
her own mind dominated by a scarlet
witch persona that's been corrupted by
the darkhold could wanda's use of
america's name be an intentional clue
from the real wanda a desperate attempt
to save the girl's life possibly
once he discovers wanda's true motives
doctor strange returns to kamertage and
helps wong fortify their defenses
they all know that the scarlet witch is
coming and they do everything they can
to prepare unfortunately none of it is
enough and the masters of the mystic
arts are quickly decimated by wanda's
assault the battle is swift and brutal
and it bears a second watch for a number
of reasons
first off there are a number of
important minor characters who take part
in the battle the green minotaur rintrow
for instance makes his mcu debut in the
comics rintra is an important sorcerer
who eventually serves as an apprentice
to dr strange himself
another one of the sorcerers who later
sacrifices herself to destroy the
darkhold is named sarah possibly a nod
to the marvel comics character sarah
wolf who works for doctor strange and
has a brief romantic relationship with
wong the battle of camertaj is also
worth re-watching for the magic alone
wanda pulls off some truly wild moves
from powerful energy blasts to enchanted
navigation of the fortress's reflective
surfaces the whole thing feels
reminiscent of classic horror movies
which is surely intentional with sam
raimi in the director's chair
doctor strange wong and the rest of the
camarata sorcerers give their all in the
battle against scarlet witch but it just
isn't enough right when all seems lost
america opens another multiverse portal
that pulls in both her and dr strange
sending them plummeting through a number
of strange worlds before landing on
earth 838
their fall through the multiverse is
undoubtedly one of the most striking
scenes in the entire movie and because
each dimension they visit is only shown
for a fraction of a second the montage
is built to be highly rewatchable thrown
all together these strange worlds make
for a striking sequence and you're bound
to notice new details each time you see
it
in order to continue her pursuit of
america into universe 838 wanda attempts
a dark magical technique known as
dreamwalking the spell allows the caster
to briefly take over the body of one of
their variants in an alternate universe
on earth 838 wanda lives a seemingly
peaceful life with her two sons earth
616 is scarlet witch then possesses her
unassuming counterparts and one of the
most affecting scenes in the movie there
are a lot of little details here that
shine brighter on a re-watch more than
anything though this scene rewards
repeated viewings because of elizabeth
olsen's performance when earth616's
wanda first takes control of her
variant's body there's a long close-up
on her face she and the audience both
hear tommy and billy calling for her
attention but she hesitates to turn and
look it's a powerful moment because it
silently conveys a rush of complex
emotions in wanda's mind
she doesn't know how she'll react to
seeing her boys in person again so she
resists the attempting urge to turn
around for as long as she possibly can
the moment is then interrupted when one
of wong's sorcerers destroys the
darkhold throwing scarlet witch back
into her original body the sideways shot
of wanda flashing back and forth between
the two realities as she desperately
grasped for her children is one of the
most haunting in the entire film
scarlet witch spends a good percentage
of doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness at mount wondagor the source of
the magic held within the darkhold from
there she's able to launch attacks
across the multiverse the scene where
wanda first arrives at wondergore bears
a second watch as it's a hugely
important moment for her character the
film goes through it pretty quickly
however with only a handful of lines
paid to the backstory of the mystical
locale long briefly mentions that mount
wundergore was once home to an ancient
demon called cathon who carved his dark
spells into the stone in the comics
cathode is one of the original elder
gods of earth who later falls to the
dark side and eventually leaves for
another dimension altogether this chaos
magic is meddled with by wanda maximoff
at an early age causing a connection
between the two the mcu has yet to fully
explain how its version of wanda became
exposed to chaos magic but wanda vision
makes it pretty clear that she had the
ability before being subjected to
hydra's infinity stone experiments
the illuminati will see you stephen
the multiverse of madness scene where
steven is brought before the illuminati
is filled with easter eggs callbacks and
other fun little details it's worth a
re-watch just to get a look at all the
characters costumes charles xavier's
x-men the animated series look is fun to
see in live action as are black bolts
comics accurate look and the official
design for the mcu's fantastic four
outfits watching the illuminati meeting
a second time also shows what fans might
be able to expect from the franchise's
upcoming fantastic four and x-men
projects patrick stewart's professor x
is a bit more cartoonish than his
counterparts in the fox movies and while
that doesn't guarantee anything about
what's to come for the mutant team in
the mcu it's interesting to see such a
distinct style in play the same goes for
john krazinski's reed richards whose
measured and even demeanor combined with
his age foreshadow a very different
fantastic four movie than the ones
previously produced if you're a die-hard
marvel fan this is a scene you'll
probably be watching over and over again
while it's fun just to see the
illuminati all assembled it's even more
exciting to see them in action and
multiverse of madness delivers that with
a brutal battle against a scarlet witch
reed tries to talk her down from her
violent path but she refuses to yield
the ensuing fight quickly turns into a
bloodbath with every illuminati member
who attacks her meeting their end like
the best action scenes in the avengers
movies the illuminati battle benefits
immensely from the sheer number of
characters in the mix it's interesting
to see the distinct ways each hero tries
to take wand down captain carter uses
her speed and wits to deliver some
tricky shield attacks while captain
marvel goes for a head first bombardment
these little details help to establish a
lot of extra depth for the illuminati
characters even in the brief time they
spend on the screen the fight
choreography is densely packed with
distinct moves and cleverly employed
superpowers and you're bound to pick up
on some previously missed moments your
second time through
the fight between scarlet witch and the
illuminati is exciting to be sure but
it's far from the most stylish action
scene in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness that honor belongs
to a later duel fought between the
steven strange of earth 616 and his
sinister doppelganger things just got
out of hand
the two meet in a desolate tower
standing alone in a universe demolished
by an incursion the evil strange is
revealed to have been corrupted by the
darkhold and a visually stunning contest
of magic follows suit the battle of the
strangest feels unlike any other mcu
fight scene mostly because of its
musical nature both sorcerers used
musical notes around the room as runes
delivering gorgeous and haunting
memories alongside their blows it's one
of the most creative sequences in the
whole movie and it bears a second
viewing on the merits of its style alone
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness becomes properly unhinged after
steven defeats his evil counterpart he
takes his variance copy of the darkhold
and conducts his first dreamwalk into
the corpse of the variant from the first
scene his necromancy is then detected by
an army of ghouls who strange calls the
souls of the damned after a brief
struggle strange brings the ghouls under
his control and uses them as wings to
fly up mount wondergore sam raimi's
influence is on full display during the
scene and not just because summoning the
dead with dark rituals is basically the
whole plot to the evil dead franchise
the director's style is also intensely
evident in the body horror and the
campiness of it all the absurd tone of
the necromancy sequence makes it a great
re-watch but a second viewing also helps
it just make more sense the well
strangeness of it all makes the whole
zombies and ghosts things a bit hard to
follow the first time through
mcu post credit scenes tend to set up
big things and the one at doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness is no
exception while walking down the street
doctor strange is accosted by a woman
named cleo played by charlize theron
clad in purple warrior garb and wielding
an impressive blade she recruits steven
for a mission to fix a multiverse
incursion and slices open a portal to an
alternate dimension for them to travel
through in the comics clea is a hugely
important character to dr strange's core
story she fights alongside him in
several battles against dormammu and
even marries him later on though her
extensive time spent in her home realm
of the dark dimension puts a strain on
the relationship if you watch the scene
a second time you'll notice that the
universe she opens at portal 2 looks a
lot like the mcu's dark dimension that
would mean both that cleo's origin story
is staying consistent with the comics
and that dormammu may be back as the big
bad of dr strange 3. check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about doctor strange
2 are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]